[Music]
okay so what's happening this weekend we
rounded up a couple of events for you
tomorrow for instance the entire family
invited to the walker pool which is up
in north las vegas they're going to have
a free pool party but it's only going to
be from one to three right in the heat
of the day you can jump in the pool
they're going to have a dj games raffles
and food all while supplies last sounds
fun all right so meantime across the
street from us here at resorts world
colombian singer maluma is taking over
with a three-day music experience it's
called maluma land and it will feature
headlining performances from the singer
himself along with shows by becky g and
dj snake among others now it'll all take
place at different venues throughout the
property with exclusive merchandise
pop-up shops and even food at the whole
venue three-day three-day event because
they're celebrating their one-year
anniversary right and you can also catch
some classic hits at fremont street
experience if that's more your vibe
downtown rock returning tomorrow night
starting at seven fans are invited to
enjoy live music and perhaps best of all
the whole experience is completely free
and it's open to all